T and
action one of the things about this game
that's really unique are these these
kind of over-the-top crazy ass weapons
that they have the gig was basically
reverse engineer from the video game
into the real world we took a look at
the broad spectrum of weapons and traps
and Sunset Overdrive and landed on four
weapons pyer hacken slay the Roman
Candle gun and te Teddy these were
weapons that we felt we could bring into
the real world what do they look like
how big are they what's the function
what's the result they sent over the
brief said hey what do you think can you
build these these crazy weapons and
traps and targets and make them work and
blow stuff up and we of course said
yes
hats off to everybody involved who built
this stuff it's very real it had to be
real figure plant and Camp Grizzly compl
completely articulated that vision and
then some to be out there blowing things
up using these weapons going from ingame
to real life action and seeing these
weapons that you've seen so many times
in the video game do their thing now in
the real world is super cool and a ton
of fun it's good all all 10 fingers
still
my